hello and welcome to a new video on code
tech tutorials continuing from last week
on gui's that you can use with your c
plus projects uh last week we covered
i'm gooey and you guys seem to like that
so i figured i'd show a couple more that
are useful and that you see in the wild
a lot wx widgets
cross platform qb library i'm going to
show you how to get this up and going
give you a quick example address a few
pitfalls that you'll probably run into
and hopefully after watching this video
you'll be able to use wx widgets just
like
wippity snip
okay let's get started with the stuff
now first of all i just want to point
out the source and it is literally this
web page if you just google search wx
widgets you will find it and there are
documentation tutorials we're going to
be using the hello world tutorial just
to prove that our app works because once
it's up and working and you know the
basics you can take it from there but
there are definitely some pitfalls in to
getting this actually running it didn't
work for me the first time i tried i
went through the tutorial put in all the
code had some strange errors i had to do
a little research i'm gonna solve all
that for you and we're gonna get right
into it
we're just gonna go and find the hello
world tutorial here here we go it's the
very first thing
now what this has is a nice explanation
of how everything works and i'm gonna
briefly go over that but i would
recommend reading this more thoroughly
if you're a little confused still
basically
we want a few main classes of course we
need the headers we'll talk about that
but you need a wx app you need this
class and you have to
override it with your own
like so so you just publicly inherit
from it and you need to override on init
so that's one class we need but there's
one other class we need so i want to
just talk about these two first and that
is the wx frame so you need a wx app and
a wx frame
and
this particular api it has
the main included which is a little
different from the stuff we usually do
here usually we write our own main
in this case what we do is we use the
main that they include and we're going
to see a little bit more about that
shortly but basically you call this
macro
and you pass it the app that you
overrode which is this one here and
that's somewhat the gist of it we're
going to have some ids you can declare
an enum like this with more ids but
there are some built-in ones that they
recommend using
and they have some examples of some some
base cases for example on init you want
to initialize a new frame and show it
and then return true and
on the frame
with your frame initialization
you want to initialize the default frame
with something like this they're calling
hello world here
so initialize the base class and then
you have all this stuff
which is basically all your menus and
everything you want to do they just have
some sample cases here
now so how does this work when you click
on buttons and stuff well it throws
events or throws the wrong word and
basically you bind it to functions
similar to something like a callback
so
you set your buttons or menus to uh
functions that you've created you can
put lambdas in here too basically you
write these functions in your frame
class
generally privately and you call them
just like well this is to set up the
call so that it just automatically
happens so you can see that this is
continued from the constructor
and they just have some examples like on
exit they say they do close true on
about they do a little message box on
hello they log a message which just pops
up a thing in your screen
and here's an example of a lambda
instead of
the function
class like we saw in the other one
there's the function pointer
and the class so you can this captures
the class
and passes an event
and there's what it actually does so you
can do it either way
and here's the entire program we're
going to go ahead and grab all this
we are going to be using visual studio
2019 community edition which is free
with a c plus workflow of course for
this tutorial you can use pretty much
anything you want as far as editor goes
this one's just nice because it handles
a lot of the additional setup for you
and also we're going to be using cmake
and we're also going to use the native
visual studio stuff so stay tuned we're
going to we're going to learn a few
tricks that you may not know in addition
to just wx widgets along the way here
and it'll be fun so let's go ahead and
create a new project and which one you
guys want to see first you want to see
cmake or visual studio
don't worry oh wait let's do just an
empty visual studio project empty
project project one we're going to call
it wx
tests are definitely a little different
so this default
solution gives us nothing we're just
going to add a source file cp file you
can give it a name if you want i'm just
going to leave the source because it
doesn't matter too much
and we're just going to put this into
our source now of course it doesn't see
it yet because it doesn't know about wx
widgets we'll fix that in just a second
but just to summarize the code because
this is probably the last time i'm going
to go over it since there's extensive
hello world documentation readily
available and it'll be probably quicker
to go through that than to listen to me
ramble on about it so we've got the
header of course there's our my app
class which has on init there's our my
frame class
which has a constructor and some private
functions to call
for things you click on or things you do
an additional id you could put more in
here if you want uh and there's our main
this is what implements the main you
gotta pass it the app
so you don't write a main which
is gonna be a little weird but they've
already written the paint wx widgets has
the main written inside it you just
gotta use this macro to call to it
basically okay and then they just define
all these functions there's the my app
on init there's the my frame constructor
as you can see it sets up all the stuff
and binds the
functions and
there's some more definitions on exit on
about on hello
all right cool so let's get wx widgets
set up we're going to use vc package
manager in a local solution so we're
going to bring up console we're going to
use control tilde to bring that up here
in visual studio and we're just going to
go new
dash item
vc
and we're going to use this
to get our libraries here i do have a
tutorial on bc package manager if you're
confused about it and i've talked about
it in a few other videos uh including
the one preceding this about i'm going
so if you're a little stuck there
i don't want to get into it again
because i've got into it so many times
but
basically what we're going to do is
we're going to open up this
json here and tell it what it needs
we're going to use visual studio code
for this
here we have our file and this of course
needs a
name we're just going to call it
wx test for now it needs a version
we'll just make it 1.0 for now
and it most importantly needs
dependencies
and in this case we just want wx widgets
you need to check the availability of
this you can open up your terminal
or we already have a terminal open
actually here in
visual studio so we can just go
bcpkg.exe search wx widgets you can do
this in your normal terminal so
this is a pcpkg thing
for library management and there you can
see it and there's this exact name so
that's what we would use here
in case you're not entirely sure oops i
just pasted the wrong thing okay so
there we go
this looks good we can close that and
now
when we go to build this it's going to
go grab all those libraries which we
will see so let's go ahead and hit build
well it failed it doesn't understand
something oh
there's one step first the properties of
this project we need to tell it to use a
vcpkg manifest very important so you
just go to your project right click on
go to properties or you can go to edit
properties that works too and under
these you'll find this vc pkg and you
can set use vc pkg manifest to yes and
that's it now it will actually use that
manifest that we just wrote and now when
we go to build it something magical will
happen
it's going to detect what we're
compiling for here
and it's going to go ahead and grab all
the libraries
it needs mainly it's wx widgets but that
needs a few other things like these
lives like jpeg tiff z live few other
required things so it's going to get
everything you need all of one go
and it tells us if we're using cmake
what to do we'll use that later we're
not using cmake it's just going to
automatically work because we're on
visual studio and it's designed to do
that
so now when we go back over to our
source here
it's still got squigglies but it
probably just hasn't updated yet let's
go ahead and build this solution
and we get a one failed this is expected
and this is one of the pitfalls i wanted
to address this here says
that it cannot invoke the main now if we
look into this
we'll find out
that this function wx implement app is
looking for win-main on windows and
that's basically the native windows
window so it's trying to launch a
windows app except we have this program
by default set to console
so so we need to set it to a window
and to do that you go back to the
properties same way and we go to the
linker
and system and look at this subsystem
here
before you change this check your
configuration and your platforms because
it only changes it for the ones you set
and that's one thing people say like it
works in debug but not release and it's
probably because you have it config for
debug but not release or something like
that so you can just set it to all
configs all platforms to make sure all
of them update in this case here
and now we want to change the subsystem
to windows hit apply okay
and now it should be a whole lot happier
let's go ahead and build this one more
time
and let's go ahead and hit play very
good there's our hello world as we
specified with that code
and you can click the buttons to run the
functions that we had there
very good
so there you go there that's how you do
it with just standard visual studio
now let's do it with cmake so we're
going to exit actually let's go just new
project cmake project
and we'll just use the default
test wait i did this backwards i called
the visual studio 1cmake that's going to
be confusing
i'm just going to call this c make real
yeah
that's that's fine
okay so we get
some bass stuff i just left everything
default here it gives us the top level
cmake that does add subdirectory for the
project here so let's go into this one
you can see the add executable
now we can put that code in here again
let's see if i still have it in the
clipboard i do perfect so i just put
that code in the cpp
we are not going to need this.h so we're
actually going to delete it
but we need to make sure we go to the
cmake and get rid of the header here
and we're going to try to do this and
i'm going to address all the problems
that come up and
teach you all the stuff first of all
we're going to add that json file to
graph the library
so i just went to the top level didn't
do file we're going to give it the same
names before
vcb json it's time we can open it
right here and we're going to do
essentially about the same thing
i'm not going to worry about this
i'm just going to type stuff for some of
these
i guess i could give it a better name wx
tests too sure
version another 1.0 make sure you have
limitations do the json thing
and last but not least dependencies
depends
spell that right i think so
no all right
so we want the same thing wx widgets
and there we go
[Music]
now i will admit this one was a little
bit more troublesome but i'll address
everything i can and show you what i
learned and how to get it actually
running because this one doesn't run as
quite as easily so now that we've got
that in here we want to do a generate
now if you've already generated and you
have an out folder over here you need to
delete that out folder after making this
vc pkg json so just know that you need
to delete that folder if you have one
now we're going to hit generate
let it do its thing it's going to have
an error and what is this error
i spelled dependencies wrong i knew it i
knew something seemed off about that oh
there's another n in there
native english speaker here doesn't know
english isn't funny that people that are
not native english speakers often write
on forums please excuse my bad english
then they continue to write perfect
english and you're like what do you mean
mine's worse than yours
not an original thought i read someone
comment that somewhere i thought it was
accurate
all right very good so this is still
generating doing its thing it go ahead
it goes ahead and gets all the libraries
just like it did before this time we are
going to use the cmx stuff so what i'm
doing is select these because if you
don't want this stuff on the side is you
click over on the left side
then you hold alt and left shift
and then you can start selecting and do
like a box select alt left shift
but you got to click and put your cursor
at the starting point and then you can
copy the entire block
control c so we're going to put this in
our cmake that has the executable and
we'll just put it right below it now and
get rid of all this other stuff it
doesn't matter
now it's going to want to generate again
since we changed to cmake go ahead and
do it it should only take a second it's
already got the libraries so
now it did have another error and that's
because when we did this copy paste our
executable name here is wx test
and over here we have the word main so
we just need to actually have the same
thing okay now should be happy
is it going to work the first time
you'll have to just keep watching and
see okay see make generation finished it
was successful
now to build this we can just go build
all and it has an error
now this is the same error as before
unresolved
main it's because once again in this
code where we're calling this
main
it's having trouble
it's basically trying to launch a
console app when we need it to be a
windows app and this is something you
adjust in cmx so we'll go back to our
cmake here and where we have add
executable after the executable name
before all the sources we want to put
win 32. if you're using mac i believe
there's mac it's like mac os subsystem
or something there's a mac version
basically so if it just crops
but win32 since we're on windows and
this is going to tell it that it's not a
console app but it's native windows app
and that we should be launching a native
window instead of
the console and that's that's just what
wx widgets wants so now we'll regenerate
here since we changed our cmake
and then we'll try to build again and
this time our build is successful
awesome so let's launch our piece of
software
it has a default startup item of the one
we just built
and that's fine it's essentially the
same as
going to your build and launching your
executable down in there this just makes
it so that it's a button here
but
when we hit play it says it can't find
some dlls oh no what gives
all right now i think this is actually a
problem with
i'm not sure what is the problem with
but this is an error somewhere someone
needs to update something because we're
in debug mode we've told it to launch a
debug we built for debug
but the library it's trying to use is
the release version why i don't know
there's probably something we can adjust
to custom change that and just to prove
this further we're going to go to this
alt where we have all the libraries
built
from that vcpkg json installed
uh somewhere in here x64 windows there's
some lives there
let's go into bin and we'll see a bunch
of dlls including the ones we're looking
for
but this is this is a problem here these
are release versions
and when we're in debug we should be
it's looking it's probably going into
here
it's looking in this folder for the
release once so someone's got a config
wrong somewhere the release ones are
clearly not in here
so
there's probably a solution to that if
you know it leave a comment down below
or if you know the place to report this
particular error let me know or report
it that's fine but the quick solution is
to just build it and release you could
manually correct the library paths but
they should be automatic like i said
there's just a bug okay so we're going
to go up here where it says x64 debug
and go to manage configurations and
we're just going to add a new one with
this plus button and we're going to
choose
x64 release
we're going to leave everything default
just save it and close it
and now we're going to switch this to
x64 release and generate
it's probably going to grab libraries
for all the release versions so it's
going to do the whole download thing
again okay generation has completed for
the x64 release we can now go back to
our startup item
and choose it it should build if it
needs to build looks like a build
started
and it succeeds and links the proper
libraries
so there you can see it works fine
and release
with cmake and i'm sure it would work
fine and debug as well if they just link
if they would just manage to link
the right versions oh oh where is this
yeah there's just something config wrong
where they're generating the wrong
libraries
but yeah the debug one should use this
ud one that's that's my analysis of the
problem i'm not sure if that's 100
correct but it's pretty telling
when you launch the thing
let's try this for the third time oh it
wants to generate before it lets me
choose a startup item fine
okay
it's pretty telling that when we
we launch in debug it says it can't find
you see the ud
or the u there it's just the standard
one the one that has d after that u it's
very subtle is for the debug what that's
my analysis of the problem so
yeah
you just have to build and release for
now unless you can
uh further figure out that problem with
cmake but there you go that's how you do
it with cmake so i've showed how to do
it with both just standard visual studio
projects and cmake while using
pcpkg.json
you should now be able to write your app
as you want basically all you do
is you design these two classes
as your program once and now as a final
thing i just want to show an example of
an app that uses wx widgets pretty
exclusively audacity you've probably
seen audacity this is using wx widgets
so
you'll see it all over the place all
right well i might cover a third one
next week let me know what you guys
think i appreciate all the support thank
you guys who have uh supported
in any way be a watch alike
a uh becoming a patron which update time
i've changed the patron patreon once
again
it is now
uh there's just one tier so if you want
to support just go over there and
support the one tier it's three bucks
essentially the price of a beer or a
coffee so if you want to throw me one of
those and help me keep generating this
kind of content for you guys that would
help a lot also the join button here on
youtube only has one tier it's the same
price essentially the same thing just
wanted to give
options on both in case you don't want
to go make an account over there or
something
all right appreciate it guys catch you
in the next one peace
[Music]
[Music]
you